SYSTEM AND IT IS IT ABOUT THAT
HELPING THE AMERICAN PEOPLE AND
NOT FOREIGN COUNTRIES.
>> Sean: 16 YEARS AFTER 9/11,
THE U.S. IS FIGHTING ISLAMIC
THOUSANDS OF AMERICANS ARE
KILLED AND NEARLY 2500.
REPORT ON THE CURRENT SITUATION
WATCH THE 60 MINUTE
CORRESPONDENT LARA LOGAN
DESCRIBES WHAT IT IS LIKE FOR
THE U.S. MILITARY IN THE CAPITAL
OF KA BLE.
>> Reporter: NOW THE VIEW FROM
THE HELICOPTER WINDOW IS ALMOST
ALL WE'LL SEE OF KA BEL.
THEY WILL STAY BEHIND GLASS
WALLS FOR THE REST OF THE TIME
IN AFGHANISTAN.
WE WANTED TO KNOW WHERE WE ARE
IF THE AMERICAN TROOPS CAN'T
DRIVE TWO MILES DOWN A ROAD IN
KABUL.
>> WE DO EVERYTHING POSSIBLE TO
PROTECT OUR FORCES.
>> Reporter: THEY ARE NOT USING
THE ROADS.
>> PROTECTING THE LIVES OF THE
TROOPS IF WE FLY INSTEAD OF DRY
AND OFFERS THEM SAFETY IT IS THE
RIGHT THING.
>> Reporter: IN MILITARY TERMS
>> Sean: LARA LOG AN IS HERE.
YOU ARE LIKE SARAH CARTER.
YOU SPENT 20 YEARS AND MORE THAN
TWO DECADES IN WAR ZONES.
YOU WERE CBSTSHGS'S CHEECH
COR71EDANT AND CHIEF FOREIGN
AFFAIRS CORRESPONDENT.
AND UP ARE STILL GOING BACK TO
THE WAR ZONES.
WHY IS THIS A PASSION OF YOURS?
>> I BELIEVE IN IT.
I BELIEVE THAT IT IS IMPORTANT
THAT WE GO OUT ON THE END OF THE
LINE TO THE PLACES THAT SOME
PEOPLE MIGHT NOT WANT OR BE ABLE
TO GO.
WE HOLD OUR LEADER AND OUR
>> Sean: YOU DO PUT YOURSELF AT
RISK WHEN YOU DO THIS.
I REMEMBER HOW AWFUL WE WATCHED
IN A MOMENT, EVERYTHING WENT
A LOT OF PEOPLE'S HEARTS ABOUT
WHAT WAS HAPPENING.
BUT YOU ARE STILL THROWING
YOURSELF BACK ININOSE
ENVIRONMENTS.
>> WHICH SHOULD TELL YOU, YOU
DON'T DO IT FOR THE ADRENALIN.
IF IT COSTS YOU THAT MUCH.
IT IS IT THAT IMPORTANT TO YOU.
IT IS IT LIKE YOU, RIGHT?
THIS IS IT THE REASON I WAS PUT
ON THIS EARTH.
I WANT TO BE THE BEST MOTHER I
CAN BE.
THAT IS IT IMPORTANT TO ME.
THIS IS IT LIKE BREATHING FOR ME
AND WHYIN WAS BORN.
>> Sean: THAT IS AN AMAZING
COMMITMENT TO YOUR LIFE'S
PURPOSE.
16 YEARS LATER IN THIS INTERVIEW
THAT WILL AIR ON 60 MINUTES, YOU
TALK TO THE U.S. COMMANDER IN
AFGHANISTAN AND ALSO TO THE
AFGHAN PRESIDENT, WHAT ARE THEY
TELLING YOU 16 YEARS LATER?
>> GENERAL MICHELSON HAS A TOUGH
JOB AND SO DOES THE PRESIDENT
THERE FOR WHAT THEY ARE DEALING
WITH.
AND SAY THAT WITH RESPECT.
I WAS TOUGH ESPECIALLY TO THE
THERE LONGER THAN ANY OTHER U.S.
GENERAL AND SERVED A NUMBER OF
TIMES AND VERY, VERY COMMITTED
TO THIS, TO SOME DEGREE, HE'S
FACING AN OVERWHELMING
CHALLENGE.
HE THINKS HE CAN WIN.
IMPORTANT THAN EVER THAT WE BEAT
ISLAMIC MILITANT TERROR AND
DEFEAT THE IDEOLOGY AND IF WE
LOSE HERE OR IF WE WERE TO LEAVE
HER, THE COST WOULD BE
UNACCEPTABLE.
EXPLAIN WHAT HE WAS SAYING
THERE?
THE PRESIDENT GAVE HIM 3000 MORE
TROOPS.
>> I SAID TO HIM AMERICANS ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT A GUY RENTING
A TRUCK FROM HOME DEPO THAN
HE SAID THAT IS EXACTLY THE
POINT.
IF YOU LOSE HERE, YOU
EMBOLDENING THE GUYS GOING TO
HOME DEPO.
AND THAT'S WHAT MAKES IT SO
THAT DRIVES EVERY ATTACK ON ANY
PART.
PLANET.
WHAT IS THE ONE THING, SEAN,
THAT NEVER CHANGED AND THEY
SHARE.
IT DOESN'T MATTER PARIS OR NEW
YORK.
THEY SHARE THE SAME IDEOLOGY.
>> Sean: THAT'S WHY IT BOTHERED
ME SO MUCH AND I WILL NOT TRY TO
GET IN POLITICS.
BUT MAN CAUSED DISASTER AND THE
RELUCTANCE TO SAY RADICAL
ISLAMIC TERRORISM LIKE THE
COMMANDER IS TELLING YOU.
WE CENTER MADE TREMENDOUS
PROGRESS.
AND I WANT TO GET YOUR
PERSPECTIVE.
DID THE RULES OF ENGAGEMENT TO
LET THE COMMANDERS AND TROOPS ON
DEGRADING OF ISIS WE HAVE SEEN?
THEY ARE PUSHED OUT OF IRAQ, BUT
IT IS A WORLDWIDE PROSPECT.
>> THE IRAQIS SAID 3000 ISIS
TERRORIST ARE OPERATING.
>> Sean: FAR LESS.
>> EASING THE RHEUMS OF
ENGAGEMENT AND THEM HAVING THE
LATITUDE FOR DECISIONS ON THE
GROUND IS IT HUGELY SIGNIFICANT.
THIS IS IT ALWAYS MORE FACTORS
ATTENTION TO WHAT THESE PEOPLE
SAY AND WHAT THEY DO.
THEY VERY OFTEN TELL YOU, THEY
TELEGRAP YOU THEIR INTENTIONS.
AND THEY SEE THIS AS PROOF, THE
FACT THAT THEY WERE FORCED OUT
OF MOSUL AND IRAQ REENFORCES
WILL NOT LET THEM HAVE THE
CALIPHATE.
>> Sean: THE COURAGE YOU HAVE TO